[Music]  here is the xbox series x user interface  in its current state  keep in mind that this is not a final  build and may not be representative of  the ui once the series x launches  on november 10th sits it's subject to  change but since we can  we figured that we would show you what  it's like to navigate the dashboard and  what sort of options you have available  with the xbox series x  you'll see quick resume in action the  snappiness of going through menus data  management  and some of the options and  configurations you can work with for  more on microsoft's next-gen system be  sure to watch my full in-depth preview  of the xbox series x  after this video  [Music]  cheers  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  so  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  my  [Music]  you